[music playing]
NARRATOR: The brown bears
of Alaska's Afognak Island
have been a danger since Morgan
set foot here two days ago.
Now they've forced
him on a detour
through unfamiliar
terrain and put
his only ride home in jeopardy.
I'm not exactly sure
where I'm at, but--
MORGAN (VOICEOVER):
I'm running late,
and uh, I'm not sure how
long the boat's going to wait
for me, So I gotta be there.
MORGAN: I shouldn't
be too far off.
Ugh.
[bleep] This isn't cove
I got dropped off in.
Definitely not.
Must be one inlet over.
I think I recognize that
square, blocky island out there
from when we came in, so
I think I just gotta get
out and around this headland.
The seas are calm
enough right now.
I could probably raft it.
NARRATOR: Morgan's four pound
inflatable raft is not designed
for ocean currents, but
it's his only chance
to catch his
scheduled extraction
before it leaves without him.
Looks to me like the tide's
just starting to come in again.
Looks pretty low right now.
So that's good, that means
it'll be washing me on the shore
and not trying to pull me out
into the open water, which
is where I don't want to be.
I'm gonna have to do something
about my paddle, too.
The hand paddles are
great in the river,
because I can use them like oars
and make really quick moves.
But paddling on flat
water trying to get
somewhere with them is brutal.
It's just an unnatural motion.
MORGAN (VOICEOVER):
So, what I need
to do is kind of attach them to
the end of a good strong stick,
and then I'll have a
kayak paddle that's
much, much more efficient.
OK.
Oh yeah.
Nice.
I think there's a little bit
of wind on the water now,
and some ripples.
Hopefully it's not
going to pick up.
I'm behind schedule pretty
significantly at this point.
So I need to get moving.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: On the Gulf
of Alaska, Morgan's risk
has paid off with a healthy
reward of salmon that will help
sustain him this coming winter.
But now he's dangerously close
to missing his ride home.
MORGAN (VOICEOVER): Really,
I'd rather not be doing this,
but it's the only way
I'm going to get there.
NARRATOR: Thrown off course
by the island's bears,
he's racing to reach
an inlet to the north,
where he's due to catch a
boat back to the mainland.
And he's navigating
only by memory.
I do know, at the
entrance to the inlet,
there was a big stone arch.
So I'm just waiting
'til I see that arch,
and I'll know for sure that
that's the inlet I need
to be going into.
But since the shoreline
is so complicated
with all these inlets
and fjords and islands,
it's not like it's a
straight, continuous beach.
And I don't know if the
boat's been waiting for me,
or already come and
gone, but hopefully
it's around the corner.
Yup, that's the arch.
Pretty distinctive land form.
And, uh, I know this is
the entrance to the inlet
that I'm going to
get picked up in.
Should be right up
here, not too far.
Hey, there's some
shiny aluminum.
Yeah, there's a boat.
Yeah, that's the one
that dropped me off.
Aw, I'm glad.
I'm ready to get
out of this raft.
MORGAN (VOICEOVER): Thankfully,
they're waiting for me,
so I should be home
free at this point.
Made it.
Thanks for waiting for me.
Sorry I was late.
Nice to be standing
on the deck of a big,
solid ocean-going boat,
versus a tiny little four
and 1/2-pound Rover pack raft.
MORGAN (VOICEOVER: ) This
trip's been a success.
I'm pretty happy
to be heading home,
and I know Margaret's going
to be thrilled with this fish.
But winter is on its way.
There's a lot of work to be
done around the homestead,
and I still have
to hit the ground
running once I get back there.